hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the joy of creation
reborn this time we're gonna be focusing
on just foxy and if you know which I'm
sure you do Foxy's a bit meaner than the
other animatronics not that the other
animatronics are huggy friendly happy
guys uh foxy is a bit of a dick I need
to preface this because the developer
said that I actually need to take
preventative measures about foxy ha you
look horrifying ignited foxy but I don't
know what the preventative measures are
it has something to do with how five
nights at Freddy's 2 had you flashing
the flashlight in Foxy's face and I
actually have 90 seconds for this one
what the [ __ ] what happened
are you okay no no what I did okay I'm
confused
I don't like this oh god okay alright
then um what the hell is happening what
the hell is happening
what do i do what do I do
Oh what do I do bro what'd I do man huh
oh god I gotta get him when his eyes are
white not when his eyes are red oh I
can't fire til I see the whites of his
eyes
this is horrible thank you oh my god I
can't touch him ah God ah ah oh God
wait wait no I'm not ready this is
horrible
okay all right okay all right brain odd
oh gods are you what is he doing what is
he doing oh god oh god oh god oh god
okay all right I'm out I'm Audi I'm Audi
whoa God okay
yeah oh yeah am i trapped I'm trapped
Oh God I'm back ah for you [ __ ]
[ __ ] you man that's such [ __ ] oh my
god I've said a thing well that's
nothing
oh I don't know where the things are oh
I don't know whether things are sweating
already
oh I'm not ready for this
oh this is every dub [ __ ] off man not
not ready I don't know where I'm going
I keep walking into the same corner Oh
God
oh [ __ ] me that's the thing that was way
too fast that was way too fast
swiggity shoes will [ __ ] you oh my god
that's so bad oh [ __ ] me God again
[ __ ] [ __ ]
how do I get away from you I don't know
what happens to trigger his eyes going
red I play I don't want to play I don't
want to play
if this was VR holy [ __ ]
my God my god [ __ ] you
what's she doing what do you mean oh my
god so scary
Shh it's so scary it's so scary man
what the [ __ ] what the hi he's made too
close
oh he's Craven he's creepy
he creeps ha ha ha
whoa where am I got him stuck mmm
ah literally the scariest [ __ ] I've ever
seen this is probably the scary it ever
seen in any game I've ever played
holy [ __ ] I'm trying I'm trying to Rack
my brain for intelligent managers oh
that is not good he's got me trapped hi
buddy
hey friend what are you doing are you
doing friend oh don't kill me don't kill
me go little little little little little
oh god it's the worst
okay the problem is like enemy oh I
can't look God how do I keep getting I
keep getting trapped in these runs hi hi
hi oh my god Tommy I don't even know
where any objects are hmm
we got a little Wow I got like listen
that's what I got to do I got like
listen I gotta like listen behind me for
the sprinting moments and then when he
sprint sighs oh [ __ ] I failed my
objective but that doesn't matter
we got Foxy's Dumber level oh oh hey
oh crap I can't get around him oh good I
still haven't even seen him kill me cuz
my eyes have been glued shut every time
he gets me oh [ __ ]
oh he's the scariest come on come on
you're wasting my time buddy
wasting everybody's time stop looking at
the light tubby nerf are you crazy
goodbye give me up for oh that was way
too close whoa whoa Nelly give me the
last one last one last one last one come
on come on give it to me give it to me
where is it
I want it come on god damn it yeah ah
that's it yes I did it identify [ __ ] you
[ __ ] come at me bro I did it okay we're
good whoa Nelly holy [ __ ] that was
amazing wow that was well done okay
hang on hi foxy good look at you oh now
that was interesting
foxy had a unique mechanic that was
different than everyone else's that was
awesome that was terrifying
that was so freakin scary those like one
of the scariest things I've ever seen in
a game it was amazing so cool oh such a
good way to implement foxy so thank you
everybody so much for watching I don't
know if I'm gonna try to be Bonnie's
he's kind of similar to Freddy but as
this game gets developed we'll see what
happens in later episodes so thank you
again and as always
see you in the next video kinda wanted
to talk